und wir schauen nach bad neuenahr
ahrweiler vor zwei monaten zerstörte die
höllen flut dort auch das zuhause von
steffi boden berg doch sie und ihre
familie haben nicht nur mit den
materiellen schäden zu kämpfen die
wassermassen haben auch seelische spuren
hinterlassen vor allem bei den zwei
kindern leon ihren maximilian etwas
alltägliches wie duschen ist für diese
beiden geschwister zum absoluten
albtraum geworden
regentropfen prasseln oder das geräusch
von wasser aus der dusche das wasser das
rauscht das ist eine alltagssituation da
hat sich der kleine maximilian aus
ahrweiler früher nie drum geschert
früher aber das war eben vor der flut
doch jetzt jetzt ist alles anders
regentropfen prasseln zu boden und in
der dusche rauscht das wasser
alltagssituationen da hat sich der
kleine maximilian aus ahrweiler früher
nie drum geschert früher das war vor der
flut jetzt ist alles anders
angst vor regen angst vor der dusche das
ist der neue alltag bei den guttenbergs
in altena situation ist so dass das nur
pushen immer bisher schwierig ist weil
da er dann auch wieder wasser kommt vor
allem
jeweils berg nahe der film nicht so toll
wäre das wasser von oben kommt das heißt
man denkt da wirklich ganz langsam an
rund zwei monate liegt die verheerende
flutkatastrophe im aartal zurück maxi
schwester leonie erinnert sich als wäre
es erst gestern geschehen
ja ich hab angst gehabt
weil
ich hatte halt auch um alle leute habe
ich hatte auch angst uns hereinbricht
bisschen
maxxi seine schwester leonie und mama
steffi boddenberg hatten glück nur ihr
keller wurde geflutet der rest des
hauses ist bewohnbar trotzdem die flut
hat vor allem seelische spuren
hinterlassen es wird dauern bis der
alltag wieder alltag ist
[Musik]
während wir sprechen jetzt mit dem
psychologen und kinder und jugend
sachverständigen sebastian bartoschek
hallo er war durchweg vielen dank dass
sie sich die zeit nehmen um uns besser
verstehen zu lassen wie sich so ein
trauma auf die psyche von kindern
auswirkt vielleicht ganz am anfang
zunächst einmal was ist überhaupt ein
trauma immer unter einem trauma
definiert man so ein ereignis von
katastrophalem ausmaß das die
fähigkeiten des einzelnen übersteigt das
zu verarbeiten und gerade mit blick auf
so naturereignisse spricht man da eben
von einem relativ sicheren trauma wenn
es eben solche
kalamitäten solche naturereignisse
betrifft
und wie üblich ist so eine reaktion
also wir wissen erst mal generell das
traumafolgestörungen im so ungefähr ein
prozent der gesamtbevölkerung auftreten
und bei denen personen die immer ein
trauma erlebt haben schwankt der
prozentwert zwischen 25 bis 30 prozent
die eben danach etwas psychisches
mitnehmen wie kann man den kindern
helfen werden die kinder behandelt
es gibt da verschiedene therapieansätze
einer der erfolgversprechendsten
insgesamt ist die kognitive
verhaltenstherapie wo man also versucht
zu reflektieren
wie kann man sein verhalten ändern wie
kann ich auch meine gefühle auch
verhaltensebene anders reagieren und es
gibt einen relativ neuen neu erforschten
ansatz aus dem letzten jahren das ist
das sogenannte e mdr verfahren die
abkürzung ist ein bisschen zu fachlich
aber es geht dann darum über
augenbewegungen tatsächlich eine
verarbeitung des traumas zu ermöglichen
es gibt bestimmte hunderte von kindern
die durch die flutkatastrophe ein trauma
erlitten haben welche folgeschäden kann
das hinterlassen
ja das problem ist dass
traumafolgestörungen sich unbehandelt
fortführen können hinzu
neben depressionen die depression ist ja
eine die tödlichsten krankheiten die
überhaupt haben weil die mit suiziden
mit einhergehen kann aber auch
nachhaltige persönlichkeits probleme
defizite in der sicherheit in dem
vertrauen zur außenwelt können sich da
bahn brechen
ganz herzlichen dank für diese
einschätzung erwartet vielen dank
[Musik]